you jumped on Cameo yeah let's talk
about Cameo Cameo yeah I was [__]
psyched when I was getting cameos on my
serve trip I was like yeah this is
paying for some some dinners and stuff
so I was stoked what was the decision to
go on Cameo with the name Shawn mcinery
versus poopies I don't even know like
was it Shawn Macer yeah oh cuz when I
looked at it it would say poopies so
yeah if you type in like jackass uh-huh
Sean Macker and he pops up oh really
that's that's that's not going to bring
in anything so I thought like you got
sobern like you didn't want to be called
poopies anymore so you're sort of
establishing yourself as Sean Macker no
let me check my Cameo is that uh how you
pronounce your last name maer yeah maer
I don't even want to know
that yeah I don't even take back I take
back that question I I I refuse to see
now it's it's on yeah there you go on
poopies yeah poopies and we had a little
fun making a video where we were asking
celebrities to say and do terrible
things on Cameo yeah I just watched the
video it's so funny is that video going
at the same time as this is going out so
they can watch it um yeah after this
right they can go watch it after this is
I I believe that this is out it it is
out yes it's out we steo uploaded it
tonight it's one of the funniest videos
I've seen in a long [__] time did
it's so great it's kind of embarrassing
now that I like watching it like the
poop one like that's the one that's
embarrassing for you it's so funny we
always ask people like how do they feel
about it's like everyone has a different
like issue with it you know and you're
like the poop I don't know nobody else
had a problem with the poop yeah no cool
yeah but it's a banger yeah and as
people listen to this we strongly urge
you to get on cameo and order a video
from poopies I can vouch for the fact
that poopies will do
anything he will say anything uh but
please don't ask him to pull out his his
wiener yeah no more nudity no more
nudity cuz that will get him suspended
again God I felt awful when we got you
suspended oh it's all good do not pull
out your wiener on Cameo yeah no ever
again well because I got a warning email
oh yeah I think that was the poop one
because you had yeah yeah your like dick
and balls were like hang from the
firefighter one cuz I did that one and
my apartment in P firefighter one would
have been the warning and then the poop
one the poop one cuz I got the good
angle on the poop one it was like my you
were already as you were talking oh dude
I had when the video starts you're like
hey guys this like you're like already
trying to like work it out um I mean
dude and in the video I said that you
know we requested poopies like take a
dump on his
pants and that we got the video back
from poopies the the request was
fulfilled within 30 minutes like that's
not a joke oh yeah I woke up and like I
seen this Cameo and I was like yeah I
was like I told Hannah I was like babe I
got another Cameo and she's like what is
it this time and I was like you're going
to like this one and he's like I don't
even I'm not filming this one yeah but
the funniest part about sayah with your
girlfriend like just taking a [__] on a
pair of pants in your room in Tahiti
well so we were in a treehouse Bungalow
so the bathroom was downstairs yeah so
luckily um I you know it wasn't in my my
room that I was staying in but it was in
like the
kitchen cuz like there's the communal
kitchen or was it just your guys kitchen
it was like so there's a tree housee it
was a communal
kitchen
no it wasn't communal I was the only one
staying there but that would have been
[__] it's like a hostel you know just
like in the the funeral request were you
like wow these people like really want
me to say this to my grandmother yeah I
truly believe that I was her last laugh
yeah like you guys did a good job yep we
really did and I'm so Gable dude like No
And and like was just like oh okay well
so um now uh like we love I love that
that video it it urges people to order
cameos from you have fun with it you
know like like let poopies shine he'll
make great videos yeah and uh we really
want to support you thanks thanks um is
there anything that you won't do he will
not show n nudity that's it only because
Cameo will want to see the nud go to Ste
ste's video nud go to the
Nudo if you guys want to see my wiener
butthole go to sto's video and check out
the cameos I I I I don't have that dude
huh I'm not putting he blurred it well
yeah it's
blurred see still yeah you can see still
see what's going on you know see what
we're talking about yeah see what we're
talking about do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is steo butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and sto's butt wipes for your
butth hole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude